the only scandal in the New York Times
piece is not about sex because they
didn't prove that or demonstratively
convince anyone of that the scandal is
that three people close to McCain's
campaign in 1999 went to a woman who's a
telecom lobbyist for PACs and
communications and other people and said
you need to get the hell away from this
campaign because it's gonna make us look
bad for whatever reason some people say
that it's a reason because of a romantic
relationship but everyone says that part
of it is that she was walking around
Washington bragging about her access to
John McCain at a time when he was
running as this big reformer totally
anti lobbyists who could never be swayed
by the iron triangle between lobbyists
and campaign contributors The Times put
a whole bunch of historical information
in there which is true and not very well
understood by the public but also old
that McCain has a history of a getting a
lot of money from various lobbies and be
doing favors for Kent campaign
contributors so this is part of that
context unfortunately the the sex angle
of it or the fare angle of it distracts
away from that and opens up the New York
Times for a kind of attack interestingly
The Washington Post did a story
basically the same story - the romance
and no one is responding to that are
calling that a big smear because it does
hold up three people from the McCain
campaign told this woman to get lost
that's kind of interesting the
short-term political effect of this is
perversely that it's going to bring
conservatives who have always been
disaffected when it comes to McCain it's
gonna bring them back to him you've
already seen that with Rush Limbaugh and
a lot of the talk radio people because
they hate the New York Times even more
than they hate arguably Hillary Clinton
and more than they hate John McCain so
that will bring them back and remind
them that you know the liberal media is
out to get you at all costs among
independents and Democrats it will be
interesting to see if this has any
effect on their idea that he's some kind
of super straight talker in all the
newspaper endorsements of him and on
editorial boards including the New York
Times they always
talk about his honesty his integrity and
the fact that he went after the
lobbyists so to the extent of which
people think about that still even
though there's plenty of evidence to the
contrary then that might hurt him down
the road but I think since it's so much
about sex that people will will just
shrug their shoulders because I don't
think at the end of the day anyone
really cares if people are cheating on
their wives or not in presidential
politics the real issue of the campaign
this is all been a distraction from it
the real issues of the campaign are
going to be basically the war and then
also the war what people are only
beginning to understand because McCain
is largely been a very unexamined
candidate is that he ran to the neocon
right of George Bush or left depending
on where you put neo-cons in terms of
foreign policy he is always advocated a
policy of rogue state rollback a
pre-emptive war you know four years
before at George Bush ever even
considered it he wants to drastically
increase the size the military the scope
of the military and he wants to sort of
draft not in the compulsory way but
civilians to be part of this sort of
transcendental fight he's always gotten
a huge amount of anti-war vote in the
primaries so eventually when it's just a
two-man race which i think it will be
after March 4th
then you're going to see a campaign
that's largely about the war largely
about McCain's interventionist policy
and there's going to be nine months of
seeing whether or not this whole
Straight Talk image is true or not and
stories like the New York Times story
helps expose the fact that he doesn't
talk any straighter than any other
politician for example in this process
he has said I've never done a favor for
lobbyists in my career this is patently
not true which you can tell by reading
his own books in which he admits it and
says that he put his personal ambition
higher than that of the country and he
feels ashamed for it so we'll have nine
months of hitting his own mythology and
also talking about his foreign policy
and his sort of sense that we all should
put our shoulder to the wheel for
national greatness which is a very anti
kind of limited government perspective
and it'll be interesting to see how that
plays out against someone like Barack
Obama